i would say starting a business is not
necessarily my life specialty but you
know of course i think the biggest thing
is finding a niche you know finding a
need for people you know that's that's
you know difficult and very very
important to being successful funding is
another big issue you know finding
people to invest in your in your company
or your product and I do know from
statistics that women do have a harder
time getting investment dollars so
that's a challenge as well and then
another key is surrounding yourself with
people who are smarter than you that is
a key to success and something that we
apply schwab
you